they say it takes 20 years to build a
reputation and five minutes to destroy
it but that isn't the case here
streamlabs who we're going to be talking
about today which is a streaming
platform they have a wide variety of
products it came out today that they
have been trying to destroy their
reputation for years trying to start
this fire testing their luck to see how
far they could take it stealing cheating
and lying their way to the top but only
just now has it caught up with them and
yes seemingly in only a few minutes most
of the streaming and youtube community
have suddenly found out what a complete
pile of flaming trash this company is i
myself have used streamlabs products in
the past both their alerts and their
broadcasting software but after today i
will never be using it again now this
situation has been evolving new
companies are coming out of the woodwork
to throw more fuel on the fire so we're
going to cover all of that for you right
now because this is a hot mess ex-ceos
are getting involved the ftc
violations are now suddenly being
brought to light cs go lotto somehow
rolls into it of course uh so we're
gonna break that down for you all right
now
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the 10
million dollar studio i'm your host
coffee zilla the internet detective now
all of this started this whole drama
with stream labs you may have heard a
little bit about it but i'm gonna break
it all down for you streamlabs is a
broadcasting software they're a company
that produces things for streamers and a
lot of people use them for their twitch
alerts as well as a fork of obs which is
a common software that people like
myself use every day to record videos or
to stream live and streamlabs has
produced a version they call streamlab
obs or slobs and due to the similar
names many people have thought that
these are similar companies or there's a
partnership between them in order to use
the same name obs i myself thought that
but this is absolutely not the case it
came out today that streamlabs has been
copying and stealing people's work for
years now and companies are hopping on
left and right like it's a damn avengers
movie to dunk
on stream labs and put the final nail in
the coffin now it all started with light
stream lightstream is one of many live
streaming tools and they posted hey can
i copy your homework they're talking
about streamlabs new product streamlab
studio they say yeah just change it up a
bit so it's not obvious you copied
clown bet and what they post i don't
know if you can see this is two things
one it's their light stream like
software copy and then right next to it
is the stream labs version and as you
can see uh they're exactly the same down
to the wording itself
like right here level up your xbox and
playstation streams level up your
console streams how does it work how
does it work and it even goes down to
the very layout of these two pages
they're nearly identical and so
obviously this made quite the buzz
nobody likes when somebody is copying
other people's products but that's when
obs which is probably the world's most
popular broadcasting software uh lit the
match and set fire to slobs obs in a
post said near the launch of slobs
stream labs reached out about us using
the obs name we kindly asked them not to
they did so anyway and followed it up by
filing a trademark we've tried to sort
this out in private and they have been
uncooperative at every turn now again
this is a uh obs is open source and so i
mean like yeah you can fork the project
but you can't literally call yourself
the same name as the thing you're taking
from you just put your name in front of
it is not suddenly yours and obs goes on
to say that they've faced confused users
who don't understand that there's even a
difference and i can attest to this
because having used both software i
didn't know that they weren't affiliated
i assume one was just one that like
incorporated stream labs into it and it
totally had the seal of approval of obs
now something that many of you may not
know is that stream labs then fired back
and said um that is not true obs project
and you know it we asked and jim said
yes proof attached this was the former
owner of streamlabs and you better
believe we're gonna get to him because
um the history here is wild but you can
see here they list an email where
they're talking about a streamlabs
github repo and they're talking about
the naming of a github repo they say we
are setting up the github to make the
code available for everyone we're
wondering the right name to choose and
we're thinking about this one streamlabs
obs and above it the obs team says sure
that sounds fine eddie i don't
particularly mind now i don't know why a
github repos name is equivalent to
naming your entire project after the
team obs like naming your whole project
streamlabs obs instead of just a github
file but apparently these guys think so
and not only do they think so they think
it's okay to then file a trademark for
streamlabs obs and why is this a big
deal well basically we came to figure
out that not only was streamlabs obs
lazily copying people but they were also
trying to poach traffic using the fact
that the two names are very similar obs
and streamlabs obs and people might
mistake them for being affiliated for
example when you type in obs to google i
think they just removed this ad um just
today because of the backlash but
streamlabs was running ads on the
keyword obs so their thing would pop up
even though the real open broadcast
software is down here again these are
not affiliated i can't believe that i
still have to point that out but i feel
like people are still going to be
confused right because if i all of a
sudden take the mcdonald's franchise
name and i call it uh coffees mcdonald's
and maybe i copy their interior layout
and make a couple changes right you're
gonna assume that those two things are
affiliated and especially if i run ads
on mcdonald's and show you my mcdonald's
thing and i do all the same things i
don't know i'd say it's fair to say that
i'm trying to use the mcdonald's name in
order to profit off it now obviously
it's a little bit different because obs
is an open source project but
nevertheless i don't think anyone likes
the fact that streamlabs obs is trying
to basically poach their notoriety and
then monetize it because yes ladies and
gentlemen that's a big part of the story
stream labs has been endlessly trying to
get money from their users while the
actual obs has been free to use forever
this is just another wrinkle in this
whole story streamlabs apparently was
even signing people up to subscribe to
their like premium service or whatever
without even letting them know and then
making it extremely hard to cancel so
yeah these people have been doing
horrible things forever but that's only
the start of what's been going on here
and i hope you understand why i'm like
so
crazy mad about this whole thing is that
i literally supported this company i
downloaded their product literally due
to their lies right or their you know
implied lie about being streamlabs obs i
literally thought they were affiliated
and many people like myself thought this
too now the stories kept coming out
after obs and lightstream told their
story it was pretty much all the
companies getting together like a
superhero movie here we have warpworld
saying that they reached out to us when
our startup was barely born about our
cryptocurrency donation service one up
coin with a let's collaborate to bring
this to more people tone only then to
take everything discussed and doing it
themselves as pioneers so we feel this
and then elgato jumped in the fray as
well
uh saying that they also got copied by
streamlabs they create the famous stream
deck and streamlabs copied it with
control your live stream from your phone
with the streamlabs stream deck so
streamlabs pretty much their mo is they
take other people's products and
innovation and they attach streamlabs in
front of it and then they make money off
of it that's that's the whole thing oh
and here's another example and i know it
just seems like everyone's just dunking
on stream labs but this is what happens
when you try to steal people's work for
years and get away with it streamlabs
also reached out to this guy he has a
company called join combo which allowed
you to like create twitch clips on the
fly and turn them into um
tick tock videos he says they were also
copied that they basically asked a lot
of prodding questions about joint combo
only to launch a copy of their product a
few months later not only that then
streamlabs employees started coming
forward and saying that people in the
company started talking about how bad um
these situations were internally and
what did streamlabs do they fired them
they fired the people talking about how
aggressive and manipulative these
practices were
this is from one of their employees
apparently so many people in marketing
were reprimanded put on pip plans and
fired for speaking up against unethical
business practices to the point where
they basically got rid of the entire
marketing team by late 2018 by the way
the irony of having to fire the
marketing team who are usually the most
aggressive in pushing towards you know
like crazy claims and stuff like that
that when you're marketing team's
basically saying hey hey hey hey hey we
gotta be kind of honest um that's when
you know that's when you know you've
gone too far but this could have
something to do with the fact that when
streamlabs was acquired by logitech they
were given compensation based on meeting
certain revenue goals so we know they
were pushed to go ahead and cr go out
and you know generate x number of
dollars so that you know the ceos and
whoever owned it would get compensated
this was actually pointed out to me by a
user named shannon on twitter and here's
the source an additional payout of 29
million dollars may be made if
streamlabs meets certain established
revenue growth targets this is right
after they were acquired so pretty much
um from the get-go all the wrong
incentives were there people were
getting fired for speaking up and pretty
much this company has had a practice of
stealing other people's work and trying
to monetize it and profit from it not
only that poaching other people's
traffic but honestly it goes back even
further than the logitech acquisition
see and this is where the rabbit hole
really starts it actually goes back to
2016
with the ftc see before streamlabs was
ever known as stream labs they were
known as something called vulcan okay
and apparently their owners were doing
some really shady stuff according to
this ftc complaint and eventually
settlement what vulcan had done was
basically uh they bought out a mobile
game company replaced it with their own
like chrome extension and were bypassing
android security features to install a
bunch of products people didn't want
onto their phone and they eventually
settled the charge um with the ftc
basically admitting guilt these are
their founders that's what they were
doing the game was called running fred
and according to the complaint quote
they used it to install a different app
commandeer people's computers and
bombard them with ads so actually if
you're hearing about this news it turns
out it's completely consistent with
these people's mo signing people up for
subscriptions they don't want stealing
other people's work and then trying to
backpack on top of that in order to make
money and steal traffic this is
literally what they've been doing from
the very beginning it's just coming out
now that it's the same company and
they've been doing it to everybody so
yes ladies and gentlemen even though i'm
not usually the type to take a big grand
stand about something like this and
frankly it's not that big of a
grandstand because you know streamlabs
obs is a terrible piece of software
anyways it's way behind where actual obs
is and there's a ton of alternatives
also to their alerts system like stream
elements but i would make a stand about
something like this either way even if
stream labs was the best game in town
because honestly you can't put up with
something like this this company it's
not like it was a bad employee in fact
it seems like it was the opposite they
fired all their good employees and left
all the bad ones who didn't question
their unethical business practices i
cannot support or have my company even
tangentially affiliated with this so i
personally am removing myself from their
ecosystem i think i still have their
software still um installed on my
computer i'll be uninstalling it and i
encourage everyone to do the same
because this is not the case of you know
a joke told 12 years ago that has
nothing to do with the company this is
the company's core product this is the
company's core values this is the
company's core business practices for
literally years i mean all of their
products a lot of them you can trace
directly back to somebody else's work
and them just stealing it now real quick
i want to jump in here and also add i
forgot it in the first recording of this
uh the cs go part that i mentioned
earlier see vulcan um back when it was
their name still this is once again back
in 2016. reports came out that they
actually
bought or co-owned the cs go jackpot
thing and they lied to people about it
they said um no we didn't but their
allegations that in fact they had a
strategic partnership running some of
these cs go websites uh now i wanna just
say for fairness that it is true that
the co-founders who started vulcan and
eventually twitch alerts which
eventually became streamlabs are
technically gone from the company but
you've seen the same practices going on
where there's always they're getting
into the shadiest stuff denying it until
they can no longer deny it i also want
to add that streamlabs did issue a
formal statement saying the following we
are taking immediate action to remove
obs from our name streamlabs obs is
built upon the top of the obs open
source platform streamlabs obs is also
open source and our code is publicly
available we take responsibility for our
actions and support the community so
there you go um not really an apology
they don't they don't say sorry but also
not really enough either at least for me
personally this goes much beyond just
the use of streamlabs as a name and also
you could have taken responsibility for
this when obs originally asked you three
years ago not to use their name and
confuse people it seems like literally
this statement is only because they got
caught which of course it is it's always
about that right and i think as eposvox
mentioned he's a he's a great youtuber
you should go check him out he always
talks about obs streaming stuff like
that
uh he mentioned that look i mean how do
you really take accountability for
a lifelong practice of stealing work
right what are you gonna give it all
back are you gonna undo all the logitech
deal right so um it doesn't really make
sense and for me it's really
unsatisfying so yeah just wanted to add
that quick context back to the video
so um to say i'm disgusted uh would be
an understatement but it's pretty
amazing to watch this thing go down and
again i know internally they're probably
gonna blame it on oh this is cancel
culture man this is this is just you
know people wanting to witch hunt i
think i saw their ceo or former ceo
talking about this no this isn't a witch
hunt this is people finally becoming
aware of who you've always been this
isn't losing your reputation in five
minutes it's people finally figuring out
what
you've been doing all along i mean
literally since your inception so that's
basically it what a wild ride this has
been i'm sure
given how much has come out in the last
24 hours we'll be seeing more come out
and i'll keep you guys in the loop about
that if you want to subscribe pump the
stock anyway thanks for watching
[Music]
but things will be different if i was
bawling